as many of us head home for the day some
animals are just getting their day
started sometimes mistaken for
hummingbirds hungry Hawk moths hover in
midair sipping nectar from flowers
pollinating them in return these agile
insects maneuver their way around
flowers that sway in the wind often with
little light to see by to test how one
species of hawk moth called the tobacco
hornworm keeps up with it's moving
flower targets researchers created
robotic flowers there's been a lot of
curiosity about how animals are able to
adjust their visual systems in order to
be able to see at low light levels the
hawk moths didn't seem to mind that the
flowers were fake as long as they got
their sweet sugary snack the researchers
tested how well the moths track the
movement of the flowers under two
lighting conditions early dusk and much
darker moonlight when the flower swayed
back and forth no more than twice per
second the moths kept up just fine
regardless of lighting any faster and
they started making mistakes especially
in the dimmest light which also caused
them to lag well behind the flowers the
researchers think the Moss visual system
slows down in dim light to boost their
visual acuity much like the shutter of a
camera that works fine as long as an
object is moving slowly but speed things
up and images start to blur so cameras
and moth eyes can't keep up but this may
not actually matter in the wild the
researchers also found that the kinds of
flowers these hawk moths prefer
naturally sway in the wind no faster
than the insects visual system can
handle it's possible plant and
pollinator have co-evolved to be well
matched for each other as the light
fades
you